- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can figure out what
x plus three times
x minus three is, and I encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can
work this out.
Well, one way to tackle
it is the way that we've
always tackled it when
we multiply binomials,
is just apply the
distributive property twice.
So first we can take this
entire yellow x plus three
and multiply times each
of these two terms.
So first we can multiply it times this x.
So that's going to be
x times x plus three.
And then we are going to
multiply it times, we can
say, this negative three.
So we could write minus three times,
now that's going to be multiplied by
x plus three again.
And then we apply the
distributive property
one more time.
Where we take this magenta x and we
distribute it across this x plus three
so x times x is x squared,
x times three is three x, and then
we do it on this side.
Negative three times x is negative three x
and negative three times three
is negative nine.
And what does this simplify to?
Well, we're gonna get x squared,
and we have three x and minus three x
so these two characters cancel out,
and we are just left with x squared
minus nine.
And you might see a little pattern here,
notice I added three and
then I subtracted three
and I got this, I got the x squared
and then if you take three and multiply it
by negative three, you are going to get
a negative nine.
And notice, the middle terms canceled out.
And one thing you might ask is,
well, will that always be the case, if we
add a number and we subtract that same
number like that?
And we could try it out.
Let's talk in general terms.
So if we, instead of doing x plus three
times x minus three, we could write
this same thing as, instead of three,
let's just say you have x plus a
times x minus a.
And I encourage you to pause this video
and work it all out, just assume
a is some number, like three
or some other number, and apply the
distributive property
twice and see what you get.
Well, let's work through it.
So first we can distribute
this yellow x plus a
onto the x and the negative a.
So x plus a times x,
or we could say x times x plus a,
that's going to be x
times x plus a,
and then we're going to have
minus a, or this negative
a, times x plus a.
So minus, and then we're gonna have
this minus a times x, plus a.
Notice, all I did is I distributed
this yellow, I distributed this big chunk
of this expression, I just distributed it
onto the x and onto this negative a.
I'm multiplying it times the x
and I'm multiplying it by the negative a.
And now we can apply the
distributive property again.
X times x is x squared,
x times a is ax,
and then we get
negative a times x is negative ax,
and then negative a times a, is negative
a squared.
And notice, regardless of my choice of a,
I'm going to have ax and then minus ax.
So this is always going to cancel out.
It didn't just work for
the case when a was three.
For any a, if I have a times x and then
I subtract a times x, that's
just going to cancel out.
So this is just going to cancel out,
and what are we going to be left with?
We are going to be left with x squared
minus a squared.
And you can view this as a special case.
When you have something, x plus something,
times x minus that same something,
it's going to be x squared minus that
something squared.
And this is a good one to know in general.
And we could use it to quickly figure out
the products of other binomials that
fit this pattern here.
So if I were to say, quick, what is
x plus 10, times x minus 10?
Well, you could say, all right
this fits the pattern, it's x plus a
times x minus a,
so it's going to be x
squared minus a squared.
If a is 10, a squared is
going to be 100.
So you can do it really quick once you
recognize the pattern.